Dragon Ball super is so stupid because
it wrecked Kahn's all the good stuff its
power scaling is out of whack and it's
ending sucks donkeys mm-hmm and how is
that different from say Dragon Ball Z
hey everyone have you noticed that in
recent years there has been a violent
annoying and annoying upswing in the
amount of people complaining about
literally everything of course you have
because the internet screams until you
have no choice but to listen so instead
of sitting back and watching the world
burn I've decided to throw my two cents
into this discussion and point out where
I think a lot of these discussions are
misguided which will almost certainly
yield insightful comments like drink
bleach apologist fangirl and who could
forget everyone's favorite make the top
10 best animated moments for this arc
you [ __ ] sellout all valid comments
that I will certainly ignore because the
comments section is cancer so let's get
on with the video here are 9 things you
are at least the vast majority of people
remember wrong about Dragon Ball super
Dragon Ball Z is a flawless diamond that
can do no wrong or at least it feels
like that's the case if you talk about
it online the major point of contention
surrounds this scene during which the
Kai's point out that fusion is temporary
for two mortals fusing and after that
the community got all up in arms oh I'm
so angry about this I can't believe they
ruin fusion and Dragon Ball Vegeta was
only there for half of the episode this
will stop me from watching next week
though and to be honest I'd be totally
down with that sickness if it wasn't for
one tiny problem Dragon Ball super isn't
the only Dragon Ball property that
retcons the original the original
retcons the original remember when an
early Dragon Ball people needed to
preserve the bodies of those that had
died so that their souls could be wish
back into said bodies well they either
completely forgot or scrapped an idea
later in the series because it was a
limiting and clunky narrative mechanic
or hava itself his regeneration is
supposed to be the same as Piccolo's
right yet he can regenerate from a
single cell team four star even made a
joke about it so when Dragon Ball super
went on and made a red Conn for the
potaro fusion it really wasn't a
standard offence unique to Dragon Ball
super it was
even the worst retcon dragonball had I
mean at this point you could argue that
if it didn't have read cons would it
even be Dragonball
my point is retcons don't prevent you
from enjoying a series like Dragonball
the sooner we all agree that all of
Dragonball are not just super is stupid
and fun
the sooner we can move past these
pointless arguments and focus on the
real problem those damn movie recaps am
i right oh well technically they are
recaps but that's kind of like saying
Christmas is about Santa I mean you're
right but also wrong there's tons more
to it than just that so I think in a way
it's misleading to say that the first
two arcs are just recaps especially when
and this is a personal nitpick the
second arc added an episode that is
arguably my favorite out of the entire
series in episode 18 to be perfectly
honest if it wasn't for the very fact
the movies look infinitely better than
the series during most of the fight
scenes which let's face it as the real
reason most people watch Dragonball then
I'd suggest the show over the movies any
day the animes version of the final of
beerus fight is arguably better and
there is a seamless transition between
the two arcs that wasn't present in the
movies you learn how vegeta came to
train with Wiese and how goku managed to
find his way there too we see Vegeta
struggle with the thought of being left
in the dust as Goku continues to soar
higher in the power department we saw
the very moment Goku and Vegeta attained
the super saiyan blue form and the
energy training they did to achieve that
control
there's also countless funny character
rich Moens one would miss by not
watching the anime so know they are not
just recaps they have added more to the
story and if it wasn't for that damn
animation then I'd recommend it every
time speaking of which I feel like I'm
beating a puddle of blood that was once
a dead horse with this one but I still
see all over the internet people
rambling about how Joey animations
bunches for Dragon Ball super well super
low here's an in-between screenshot put
side-by-side with a key frame from one
of the old movies to prove my point
please stop doing this it's not only
wrong but it gives off the incorrect
notion that you have any idea what the
hell you're talking about
Dragon Ball super xanimation troubles
were and always have been due to their
tight schedule as an artist who knows
some fantastic artists it doesn't matter
how great the artist is if they don't
have enough time to draw Goku
he's gonna look like a [ __ ] burn
victim or worse if you wish to educate
yourself as to how they improved and yes
they have improved considerably since
the early arcs then I recommend checking
out anime a J's channel the link is in
the description down below this is gonna
sound stupid but did you know that there
are actually people out there who think
Akira Toriyama draws the entire show
every week what do they think Toei
animation is filled with just Akira
Toriyama with a bunch of markers and
paper but I digress this is not to say
accurate Toriyama doesn't have any input
but he might do less than you think
his work includes outlining much of the
story through bullet point style
instructions and he also provides
character designs on occasion for some
of the cast but not all of them Toriyama
successor to the Dragon Ball manga helps
him with that as well as the Toei
animation staff but that's about the
extent of it Toei animation has a full
staff of writers who you guessed it
right the episodes based off of limited
to no instructions from Toriyama
depending on the episode the same is
true for Toyo taro he largely writes the
manga based off of Toriyama's
instructions this is why you will see
huge variations between the manga and
the anime while they both in a
roundabout way hit the same story beats
okay this one is my favorite so spoilers
came out potentially revealing how
Dragon Ball super would end and if it
ends the way people think it will end
they are going to be complaining now I'm
not saying that you have to like it
feel free to not like it but I am saying
that you shouldn't use this as another
reason to bolster your argument as to
why you prefer Dragon Ball Z / super I
mean did you not see Dragon Ball Z's
ending Goku hadn't seen Bulma in years
he says peace out to his family on a
moment's notice to train some child that
we the audience and they the cast had
never heard of the end it doesn't matter
how rose-tinted your glasses are that
has a very unsatisfying ending even GT
did it better and I feel sick after
saying that but the best part is when
the news broke of supers potential
ending everyone was so upset talking
specifically about how it was so
predictable predictable was it well it's
a good thing I had the foresight to put
up a poll on my channel asking you guys
who you thought
win the tournament of power I put this
up three months ago around the time of
episode 120 so not too far away from the
ending either with 11,000 votes cast
these were the poll results for who they
thought would win at that time cheering
got 8% of the vote
Gohan and Frieza came in with 13 and 14
percent respectively Vegeta had 18
percent and finally Goku had 48 percent
of the overall vote and these were the
comments
[Music]
so yeah nope you guys were totally right
the ending was too predictable I want an
analysis of the beam width and height
Scott will yes sir that could take days
to assess both of their power levels if
we comb through this series [ __ ] time
for this William this job just [ __ ]
push out what it counts most how the Mac
just doesn't add up
every formula every equation the power
levels just don't [ __ ] get it
hundreds of people we can't figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on in this scene
who's the strongest Goku huh you say God
put me in the [ __ ] eyes and tell me
that [ __ ] right [ __ ] yelling
this stroke is gonna Super Saiyan God
[ __ ] coward sir when what if he's
just you know holding back oh [ __ ] it
was your day now with a [ __ ] shotgun
you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
the power levels don't make sense the
power levels down max
I know this is my opinion but I feel
like trying to boil down what is
essentially what's going to make the
story interesting two mathematical units
is pretty stupid
honestly I understand there are some
definite times where there's a lot of
inconsistency like I said but people
really just don't want to accept the
characters a don't always fight at full
power and every scene as well as be
inconsistent power levels have kind of
been a staples of the franchise at this
point that video you just saw was made
by a talented man called the pinwheel
here on YouTube he recently made a video
discussing power levels and the toxic
Dragon Ball community on YouTube which I
found hilarious and hugely entertaining
if you guys want to see more from him
I'll leave a link to his channel also in
the description down below but in short
he is completely right and put it better
than I ever could
Dragon Ball super did not ruin power
scaling it simply continued the trend
that Dragon Ball had been on since that
aspect of the show had been introduced
so here's a nice complex rule of thumb
for why the series creates certain
scenes all right are you ready here are
the things that they consider
step one would it be cool there are no
other steps one thing I will say about
Dragon Ball super is that they managed
to cram in all the characters that they
didn't use in at the end Dragon Ball Z
totally left out a ton of their
characters from the original run looking
at you launch heck I bet even some of
you out there don't even know who launch
is Dragon Ball is a device used to sell
toys nothing more people can shout nag
you the tiny nuance narrative choices of
Dragon Ball like it was there past you
dissertation all they want but in
reality all fans lost after in Dragon
Ball is that sweet vision will cocaine
[ __ ] Gohan Blanco is the best example
of this or even Super Saiyan 5 people
love those even though they make no
narrative sense and are [ __ ] stupid
oh wait no it didn't Dragon Ball ruined
bulma's hair and then Dragon Ball Z
confused it further by making trunks his
hair the color his mother's should have
been back in Dragon Ball I mean it's not
like black plus blue equals purple in
short or Amma initially wanted Boas hair
to be purple but they made it blue and
ran with that that's why you'll see in
certain movies and act from Toriyama she
has purple hair all super did was make
his hair consistent in universe with
what it should have been day one they
did what they could to make it work
better so stop talking about it like
it's some reason to hate the show it's
not Goku never wins in Dragon Ball super
oh sorry I stand corrected prior to the
tournament of power Goku had defeated
without the help of others botom oh and
Bergama thrown a few thugs and that's
literally it he lost to beerus
he lost the Frieza he surrendered to hit
he lost to Goku black and he lost to
fuse imasu Dragon Ball super has been
the longest most consistent losing
streak for his character even Vegeta has
defeated more characters in this series
than Goku right off the top of my head I
can think of takuma sorbet frost magetta
cava heck even if you include the
torment of power Vegeta has still more
fighters defeated than Goku in this
series you might think I'm trying to
defend Super from criticism here I'm
really not there are plenty of issues
that affect
super exclusively and if you want to
discuss those then go right ahead but if
power scaling Goku's plot armor and
trunks is [ __ ] hair are what you're
fixated on then you need to realize that
the reality is super inherited these
problems from Dragonball Z that flawless
gemstone from your childhood has more
holes than Swiss cheese but what do I
know
I only voted for Frieza
thanks guys for watching if you have
thoughts on any of the points I've made
don't forget to rate the video and let
me know down below how you feel if you
guys want to see more Dragon Ball
goodness from me why not try a
subscription on for size I upload every
week at the same time but that'll do it
for this week I've been totally not mark
thank you so much for watching